les boulangers face à l'explosion du
prix de l'électricité ils vont notamment
bénéficier d'un report des impôts et des
cotisations sociales annoncent mardi de
la première ministre loin d'être
suffisant estime certains quand la
facture est parfois multipliée par 7
vous voyez ce reportage à par ces
mesures et jouer les tours de Faustine
du Nord
pour aider les boulangers inéligibles
bouclier tarifaires l'état vient
d'annoncer la mise en place d'aide
supplémentaires pour faire face au coût
de l'énergie ils auront désormais la
possibilité de demander en 2023 un
report de paiement de leurs impôts et
cotisations sociales de bénéficier de
l'amortisseur pouvant prendre en charge
jusqu'à 20% de la facture d'électricité
ou bien de résilier sans frais leur
contrats trop cher mais pour Yann doit
Dick qui a racheté cette boulangerie de
parsemêler en septembre 2022 ces aides
sont loin d'être suffisantes au vu de
l'augmentation en seulement quatre mois
il a dépensé 14000 euros d'électricité
soit l'équivalent de ce que sont
prévisionnel annonçait pour un an que ce
soit des reports de charge que je
paierai plus tard pas maintenant mais
plus tard je vois pas trop le bénéfice
et puis un amortisseur de 20% quand ça a
augmenté de 400 mais moi c'est 400 mais
il y en a c'est bien pire enfin moi à
court terme bah oui effectivement je
pense à déposer le bilan étant donné que
c'est pas une entreprise qui est viable
par semaine pour quelque chose où on
gagne pas d'argent pour la Fédération
des boulangers d'Indre-et-Loire la
crainte est de voir des boulangeries
mettre la clé sous la porte car selon
elle les aide ne sont pas un moyen
pérenne la seule solution plafonner la
hausse des prix de l'électricité je
pense que le X 2 effectivement par un
jeu un petit peu d'augmentation sur nos
tarifs comme ça peut-être que celui-là
on peut l'absorber par contre je lui dis
après du x 3 du X 4 du X 5 celui-là moi
si demain j'ai une facture de 5000 de
7000 euros d'électricité par mois alors
effectivement je vais avoir peut-être
2000 ou 3000 euros d'aide de l'État mais
ma facture elle sera toujours à 4000 ces
aides elles sont elles sont elles sont
importantes mais c'est pas ça qui va
faire que l'économie elle va pas
s'effondrer derrière je pense que une
entreprise habite pas avec des aides
elle peut traverser un une tempête mais
là les tarifs actuellement pratiqués
enfin je veux dire c'est on est sur sur
quelque chose qui est pas raisonnable ce
jeudi Emmanuel Macron a annoncé que les
fournisseurs d'énergie renégocieront dès
janvier avec les artisans dont les
contrats d'électricité
les 280 euros du mégawattheure